abone ol
bu
sayın hocam beni Başkanım Geldi mi
misafirler
bu Gazi Osman Çakmak
bu Tokat Zile narlıkışla köyünde doğdum
Çiftçi bir ailenin V çocuğum
Allah hepimizin birlik ve beraberlik
içerisinde
bir tek bir hedefi vardır tek bir amacı
vardır Bizim de annelerimiz babamız ve
değerli öğretmenlerimiz bizi bu şekilde
yetiştirmiştir ki ay yıldızlı bayrağına
sahip çık İnsanı yaşat ki devlet yaşasın
politikasıyla her zaman devletimizin
birliği ve beraberliği için mücadele
ediyoruz çok çok özür dileyerek biraz
daha rahat edebilmek için sizlerden özür
dileyerek bu
18 yaşında aklım ermeye başladı rahmetli
dedemin kuzularını gidiyordum ve ilk
okurumun alırsa İlköğretim Okulu'nda
devam ettim 11 yaşında aklım ermeye
başladığında bir cuma günü İstiklal
Marşı okunurken
şenge cumartesi pazar olması vesilesiyle
ay yıldızlı bayrağımızı göklere çekmemiz
gerekiyordu hocam da dedi ki Çocuklar
bugün bayrağımızı çekmeyeceğiz değerli
Osman Hocam buradan Kulakların için
atıyorum neden hocam dedim Çünkü küm Ak
Ara ara çalışmıyor Hocam ben de çıkarım
o bayrak köfte Dalgalansın cumartesi
pazar da düşersen bir şey olur diye Ocak
çıkarım Arkadaşlar yardım eder ve o gün
itibariyle başladım Var mı bir isteğin
dedi var hocam dedim Ben bugün çok güzel
bir maç izledi bu Milli takım maçı
izledim hayallerin hayalini kurdum
ailenin V çocuğum ya 5 numaralı formayı
milli takım formasını giyip ülkeme
hizmet etmek istiyorum ama buralarda çok
zor Babam İstanbul'a gidiyor annemle
konuşur musun Ben de İstanbul'a gitmek
istiyorum toz olmak için söz konuşacağım
dedi ve annemle konuşurken Annem şöyle
bir cümle kullandı Ben Evren Saydım
olmaz ama Osmanlı kıyamam dedi ya ben de
annem izin verdi dedim kıyamadığı için
beni gönderirdim babam
kışın Tokat'ta yazın İstanbul'da yazın
İstanbul'da kışın Tokat'ta çalışarak
ailesini geçindirmek için çok büyük bir
arazimiz yok Onun için de aile de
kalabalık olunca Babamla beraber
İstanbul'a gittim marangozhanede
çalışmaya başladım ve orada İstanbul
Zeytinburnu sporun alt yapısına gittim
ve seçildim futbol olan açtım heyecanım
şundan dolayı anlatıyorum ki önümüzde
bir hedef vardır önümüzde bir amaç varsa
hedefin doğrultusunda inandığı yolda
Asla Pes Etme Ben de bu mücadelenin
içerisine hem aramızda ne de çalışıyorum
Hem babama yardım ediyorum hem de
antrenmanlara gidiyordum ve sen
inledikçe Ben de tam böyle profesyonel
olma aşamasında sola yandan sakatlandım
profesyonel olamadım ama iki albümde
askere gitmiştir Bu ailenin tamamen
YouTube Benim de babamın omuzlarında
Aydın ve bekar evinde kalıyorduk baba
dedim yurtdışına
Usta götürüyorlar ben yurt dışına
gidebilir miyim Rusya olur mu Yaşın çok
küçük askerini yapmayalım oraya götür
mezler baba dedim öyle bir şey gibi abi
ile tanıştım seninle tanıştırmak
istiyorum evine mobilyasını yaptım çok
mutlu oldu Senin yurtdışına götüreceğim
ve bizim şirketimizin en iyi personeli
olacaksın diye Ben de babam da izin
verdi ve yurtdışına gittim yurtdışında
çalışmaya başladıktan sonra tekrar
ülkeme döndüm ve iki tane abim 13
İncirli'de bir İzmir'de askerlik vatani
görevini yaptığı her Türk evladının
yapması gereken bir görevdir bir araçtır
Bu epogam biraz uzaklaş Mıştım
Hayallerim yavaş yavaş sönmeye başlarken
tekrar amatör bir kulüpte yeni doğan
güneş sporda futbola devam ettim ama bir
baktım 20 yaşına gelmişim 20 yaşında
hepimizin Vatan borcudur askerliğini
yapıp gelip öyle devam edeyim dedim
futbola ve ticarete ve ülkemiz hizmet
etmek için her anlamda hizmet ediyoruz
ya
bu Manisa Doğu Kışla Şırnak Besta
devamında
ve bölücü terör örgütünün döşemiş
olduğum Ayna
sabah operasyonda basması sonucu sol
ayağını kaybetti muayene bastığım an
komutanım galiba Ben Vuruldum dedim Yok
evlat Sen rahat ol butonun ipini bağla
seni şimdi arkadaşların oradan alacak
dedi Ben de Komutanım ayağıma baktığımda
bunun ipi yok o zaman sağ botunun ipini
bağlansa Batumlu ipimi çıkarıp ayağının
işten turnike yaptım ve kahraman Tüm
kardeşlerimiz hep birlikte güçlüyüz ya
beni oradan alıp ambulansa ambulansla da
büyük bir devletin evlat olmaktan gurur
duyuyorum
da helikopterle Şırnak Devlet
Hastanesi'ne Şırnak Devlet Hastanesi'ne
indiğinde inancı çok üşüyordum
abone ol
Bir
tümen komutanı beni karşıladı evlat Var
mı bir isteğin dedi şöyle tatlı bir
dokunuş yaptırdığı sıkıldım onun baba
şefkati anne şefkati samimi bir şefkatle
ısırdım ve kendime geldim komutanım ben
çok güzel futbol oynuyorum bir de annem
küçük yaştan beri yanından olmadığı için
biraz aşırı düşkündür ayrımı kesmeyin
annem bu acıya dayanamaz dedim söz
evladım dedi en iyi şekilde an
tansiyonumuz gerçekleşti ve Şırnak
Devlet Hastanesi'nde Diyarbakır'a
GATA'ya geldik Annem geldi ben Ahmet
Dedim ki annem getir orada Kahraman
mehmetçiklerimiz var ağabey bakalım
birliği ve beraberliği için İki gözünü
kaybetmiş iki ayağını kaybetmiş Ben
sadece ufak bir Beyler ödemişim annem bu
kahramanlarda görsün protezi
gösteriyorlar Ama daha önce görmemiştik
ilk önceleri vardı ya Orada bir engel
var o engelliye Dokunma yapamazsın
başaramazsın değil ben de kendimi
annemin üzüntüsüyle beraber daha çok
güçlü olmam önüne çıkabilecek her türlü
engeli açmam gerektiğini anneme söz
verdim ve o gün itibariyle güçlü bir
şekilde ayağa kalktım bireysel olarak
hızlı geçmem gereken konular var ve
Ben köye geldim ötesini taktım
Osman Çakmak olmak için önüne çıkan tüm
engelleri açtım ve anneme bir ceza
kırmama kararı aldım canım annem ben
küçük yaşta senden ayrıldım İstanbul'a
gittim hayallerin peşinde koşarken seni
unuttum özür dilerim Şimdi senin
yanındayım Ve evlendim Ellerinizden
öperim Üç tane çocuğum var İki kızım bir
oğlum var Ve annemin yanında kalmaya
karar verdim toprakta şehit aileleri
yardımlaşma derneği kurdu kurulmasında
kuruluşunda çok büyük emek sarf ettim
Şehit Ailelerimiz bizim için çok
önemlidir Çünkü onlar ağır Bedel
ödediler Biricik evlatları dediler
Biricik eşlerine dediler birleşik
babalarına ödediler u ülkenin Birliği
beraberliği için ve ben onlara hizmet
etmek için zaten
Devletimiz bize bir maaş veriyor
oy oy hizmetlerde olursun da baktım
ampute futbol dünyada var olan bir şey
Türk Silahlı Kuvvetleri haftası
merkezinde hafif futbolun gazilerimizi
rahmetle edelim amaçlı başlanan branşta
Ben de o ailenin bir parçası olmak
istedim Ama kafamda hep kurduğum
hayaller vardı Acaba olur mu diye ve
2011'i takıma seçildim
2010'da Arjantin'de Cenabı Allah küçük
yaşta 11 yaşında hayal ettiğim
ay-yıldızlı formayı kocamdan bugüne
kadar hiçbir şey istemedim hep hocamın
peşinde koştum Ama hocam bana 5 numara
verir misiniz dedim hiç Gerçekten beni
çok hastayım bu 5 numara ya dedim ve o 5
numaralı formayı hocam da kırmayarak
verdi ilk milli forma milli mi başım ve
5 numaralı formayla sahada arkadaşlarla
beraber İstiklal Marşı'nı okurken
Arjantin maçında gerçekten çok
duygulandım heyecandan kendime gelemedim
o 11 yaşında O Can'la beraber
bu maçı da 3-0 kazandı güzel bir gol
attı Önemli olan benim gol atmam değil o
maçı kazanmamız the ve dünya 3'üncüsü
olduk 2012 bunu suya kare bıraktı dünya
üçüncülüğü 2014 Meksika'da dünya düşünün
burada bir biraz daha bu işi şampiyonu
olan bir takım var Neden Biz olmayalım
diye o camla devamlı proje yaptım ve
yardımcı olmaya çalıştım var olan
engelli kardeşlerimizi sosyal medyanın
desteğini alarak ulaşmamız gerekiyor
yetenekli engelli kardeşlerimize doğru
engelli kardeşlerimizle beraber 2017
Avrupa şampiyonası'nın ülkemizde olması
için mücadele ettik ve sağ olsun devlet
büyüklerimize Bu konuda bize yardımcı
oldular
da aynı anlamda da şöyle bir proje vardı
2014 yılında Şampiyonlar Ligi'nde
Şampiyonlar Ligi şampiyon olduğumuzda
Osman attı şampiyonluk geldi bunu
Mehmetçik vakfımızın şehit ailelerimize
ve Gazilerimize bizim çocuklarımıza
eğitim yardımında bulunan il Mehmetçik
Vakfı vardı ve bana dediler ki Bu
projede yer almak ister misin ne demek
dedi bir bedel Ödeyeceğiz Bedeli zaten
ödüyorsunuz dedim şehit ailelerine ve
Gazilerimize Ben gönüllü olarak
oturacağım içinde yer almak istiyorum
2014 Osman attı şampiyonluk geldi 2017
yılında Vodafone parkta çok büyük fiyat
45 bin kişi önünde
bu final maçında Cenabı Allah öyle bir
şey nasip etti ki
İngilizler karşısında 1-0 ödedik bizim
müsabakalar 50 dakika sürüyor bir gün
oldu takım kaptanı takımın abisi
çocuklar çok güveniyor bana Ben de dedim
ki işte orada Hadi arkadaşlar elinize
kadar ingilizlerden bir gol yedik ve
müsabaka 1-1 oldu bu iş ne dedim Hadi
dedim ve toparlandık son saniye golüyle
o 45 bin kişinin karşısında Cenabı Allah
onu bana nasip etti Osman attı
şampiyonluk geldi
bitti mi
bitmedi
2018 Dünya Kupası dünya şampiyonası
bu dünya 41 Rusya
5000 ev sahibi Meksika 4000
bu İrlanda 40 Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'ne 5 artık ve final maçına
kaldık finalde bir rezil devletler Kenan
dola geldi Ankara ile karşılaştık normal
50 dakika 0-0 bitti 70 dakika 20 dakika
da uzatması ile beraber 00 bitti
penaltılara gitti Kocam dedi ki 3. Penti
sen atacaksın Ocak 5 yapsam olur mu
dedim ben 5 Kasım'da ama yine basmıştı
dedim bugün de beş Kasım dedim Başka bir
arkadaş Kaptan gemiyi sıkmayacak kişisin
Tamam o zaman hocam neyi uygun
görüyorsunuz Tamam beş saat dedi ve beş
penaltı bizim kaleci tüm golleri ince
506 dağ Bana Kaldı Bende kaçırınca dünya
için solduk
O çok mm aynaya bakmam gerekiyordu
Allah'ım sen yardım et dedim hani
düştünüz güçlü olmamız gerekiyor ama
geldikten sonra Allah'ım iyi ki gençlik
kardeşim bu tarafta kaçırmadık açılmamış
Ben kaçırmak bana nasip oldu bir Eğer
Birlik açılacaksa İyi ki lan kaçırmışım
değil
şükrettim ve devam ettik Ondan sonra
Futbol Kariyerim izin dünya ikincisi
oldu futbol kariyerinin Sonuna Geldik Bu
sefer 100 de 50 olan bir yetkin yüzde
yüze çıktı yüzdeyüz Yetkin varken takım
üzerindeki yetim Milli Takımlar Teknik
Direktör oldu önüne bu süreçte engel
çıkmadı mı Çıktı Ama iyi insanlarla
çıktı hepimizin ortak bir noktası vardır
annemize babamıza sağlık bir evlat olmak
Eğer annem babam evlenmemiş olsaydı
bugün burada konuşma kim yapacaktı bu
ve o koltuklarda kimler oturacak the ve
en önemlisi bir anne evlatsız yapabilir
Bu bir evlat da annesi yapabiliriz beni
hatuna dediği gibi bir ama bir evlat
asla vatansız yapamaz
Onun için
milli takıma birkaç tane Osman Çakmak
kazandırabilir miyim var olan engelli 12
milyon engelimiz var ve 12 milyon engel
içerisinde 3000000 ortopedik engelli var
tekerlekli sandalye basketbol ampute
futbol masa tenisi halter oturarak
voleybol buna içersinde nampi futbola
yakın olan
arkadaşlarımızın seçip milli takım
hocası olduktan sonra 57 tane değişik
bolca şans verdim ve 13 tane Kahraman
Osman Çakmak roketsanda çalışıyorum
birinin adını roket bir fiziğe bir havai
fişek gibi motivasyon konuşmaları ile
aziz istek hız inanç Duygu ve samimiyet
aile birliği Hepsini bir arada toplayıp
iyi bir takım oluşturmak için Avrupa
şampiyonasına kendiliğinden dolayı
2020-2021 yılına ertelendi dv2021
yılında da
grubunuzda İtalya Gürcistan Hollanda
olanda panelinden dolayı gelemedi Bak ne
kadar düştü Bir ülkeyiz bizim sağlık
çalışanlarımız Biz de oraya gönderdi Bu
konuda çok şanslıyız de onlara da millet
Dalan saygı duyuyorum Her zaman her
mesleğe saygı duyduğumuz gibi dedim ki
eğitim güncel eğitim antrenman ve
topları Sizler profesyonel bir
futbolcusunuz asla sizlere kimse engelli
gözüyle bakmıyorum önce sen kendini
bu profesyonel bir futbolcu geliyor
aynaya baktığımda Evet Osman Hocam
bundan bahsetmek istiyorum
Ama sen de bir engel açabilirsin bir
genç kardeşlerimizle beraber inandığımız
yolda gittik Gürcistan'a ilk maçınız
Gürcistan 10-0 İtalya 0/11 göz açtırmadı
Çünkü aynı empati kurabiliyorum benim
hayatımdaki en büyük önem kazanan
cümlelerden biri empati Tea senin
karşıya Eğer bir empati kurabiliyor sana
Aynen Parti'yle karşılaşabilirsin onlar
olmuş olsaydı onlar da güzelsin atardın
ve son dünya şampiyonu bir 2012 yılında
Dünya şampiyonu olan Rusya 2014 yılında
Dünya şampiyonu olan Rusya ve 5 gol de
yendik
bu İlhan Bey tekrar yarı finalde 40
çeyrek finalde 40 Rusya'yı beşlik yeni 5
gerek ve finale yükseldik finalde rakip
İspanya ya dedim ki arkadaşlar bugün
anlamını ve önemini biliyormusunuz
biliyoruz hocam bugünün anlam ve önemi
nedir
en başta ulu önder Mustafa Kemal Atatürk
olmak üzere tüm Gazilerimize ve
şehitlerimize şehitlerimize minnetle
anarken Kahraman gazilerimizin 19 Eylül
Gaziler gününde bir final maçı
oynuyorsunuz Ben bugüne kadar 247
antrenmanda size her şeyi verdim
O bizim elimizden gelen buydu Bu saatten
sonra Mehmetçik Vakfı çok güzeldi reklam
videosu vardı düşen askeri kaldırıyor
mayına basan Osman'ı arkadaşlara
ambulansla götürüyor zaten şehit olan
kardeşini Osman Kaptan elleriyle
tabura getiriyor Bunun için mücadele
edin
en son bitiş düdüğü ile beraber bana
gelecek bir sevinç çığlıkları kalmasın
Allah hepimizi bu eğitim çok önemlidir
disiplin çok önemlidir eğitime önem
vermemiz lazım vermiş olduğu eğitimle
doğrusuna o arkadaşına moral ve
motivasyonu çok iyi Yüklemen lazım ve
çocuklarda çıktı Aslanlar gibi ben 5
dedim hani 5 numarayı çok seviyorum
kardeşlerim de altı atarak TRT 1'de
yayınlandı gibi tüm ülkelere sayısal
üstünlüğü sağlayıp ve 6-0 Galip gelerek
85 milyonu ve gaziler gününde o iki gözü
görmeyen Gazilerimize Polonya'nın
telefon şehrinden kupayı alıp Türkiye'ye
getirdiler
de dedim ki İşte inanan bir millet budur
isteyen arzulayan hep içimizdeki Seyit
Onbaşı lar gibi bi rahmetli Muhsin
Yazıcı nolur bir cümlesi vardı Hiç
unutmam şöyle bir cümle kurmuştur Biz
doğmuşsa
kefenimizi giydik Bugün bizim için nedir
ki ki onun için sizde tebrik ediyorum
arkadaşlar değerli kardeşlerim sizi
yetiştiren ananın babanın elinin
ellerinden öpüyorum 13 tane Kahraman
futbolcu ile beraber teknik ekiple
beraber Payı aldık ve tüm devlet
büyüklerimize bizi araması siz değerli
hocalarımızın ve genç kardeşlerimizin
dualarıyla mutlu bir şekilde Polonya'dan
ayrıldık sen beni mutlu eden en önemli
şey orada Mehter Marşı çalması orada 14
tane ülke var en üstte bizi koyup oraya
yanına ay yıldızlı bayrağı koymaları
iş bitti Ne bitmedi önümüze çıkan her
türlü engeli aşmak için mücadele
edeceğiz evet Ben bir deliyim Ben daha
Bedeli diyenler de vardır ama bizim
önümüze bir engel çıkabilir bu engeller
ile karşılaştığımızda bu engelleri aşmak
için de mücadele edeceğiz yeni olan bir
ülkede bizim için en önemli olan
konuştu ki Bu vatanın birliği ve
beraberliği için her türlü fedakârlığı
yapmaya hazırız
bu genç kardeşlerimize bir araya
geliyorum genç kardeşlerimizin bizden
istekleri şudur ki hocam Hiç pes etmeden
Hiç mi önüne engel çıkmadım Evet önüne
çıkan engelleri iyi insanlarla
çok değerli eğitimi Öğretim üyelerimize
istişare yaparak ve devamlı kitap
okuyarak insan psikolojisi sporcu
psikolojisi
bu çocuklarımızı bu şekilde yetiştirsin
şu anda sizler gibi koltuklarda
Dinlediğiniz gibi aynı şekilde iki
kızmadan anlattım şey olarak şunu
söylemek istiyorum ben ben evlendiğinde
eşine bir şöyle bir cümle kullanmış
Osmanlı ayağı Yok ya sizin de acaba
Çocuğunuz olduğunda engelli mi olacak
diye
bir süre biliyor musunuz
Bu bir Sinem bizim dünyaya geldiğinde
eşim ilk elini uzatmış ayağı var mı diye
yok bizde öyle bir toplumun milleti için
Asla Pes etmeyin mücadele edin Şimdi
kızını bir şekilde okuyor Diğer kızın da
en çok sevdiğim bir meslektir ki
ülkemizde her türlü mesleği aşığız ama
insan psikolojisi çok önemlidir Ona
dedim ki kızım bir baban olarak bir Gazi
Osman Çakmak olarak senden bir şey
isteyebilir miyiz tercih yaparken
psikoloji bölümü tercih eder misin diye
şu anda kızım da psikoloji bozuk da hani
like at yaprağı dibine düşermiş ya o
futbolcu olmak için güzel değildi
2020 yılında buraya gelip konuşma
yapacaktık ama pembe mi den dolayı 2021
yılına ertelendi söyle tatlı bir cümle
ezanı Muhammed okunurken bitirmek
istiyorum
2020'de olmayan bir şey 2021'de
gerçekleşiyor Önemli olan inandığın Pes
et Bey mücadele edin zaman dilimini çok
iyi kullanmamız lazım bazen zaman dilimi
içerisinde olumsuzluklarla
karşılaşabiliriz Ama Asla Pes etmeyin
çok değerli kardeşlerim
Değerli hocalarım beni dinlediğin için
çok teşekkür ediyorum İyi ki varsın